I enjoyed watching some of your videos
where you were being made up and you
were getting ready to go on to set and I
also saw some videos think we had no
makeup on and you're naturally beautiful
thank you and then when you put this
makeup on it's like this is actress this
princess emerges and I'm wondering what
you tell yourself when you are getting
made up and that walk that you take from
the makeup room to the set like this
everything's in place the hair the dress
the eyelashes the lipstick everything
nothin but what is it inside that you're
also taking with you because something
else comes out well then it's not just
the physical mm-hmm wow that you know
again that goes right back to 11 basic
thing I believe in living in the moment
you know that moment when the
transformation is happening I am there
one hundred percent I am actually
feeling that a new character is coming
alive I feel like you know and this it's
almost like a mask is being put over
Kalpana and whoever it is you know in my
films neelima or wrong fellow he or
whoever it is like she's actually is it
to me it's like a it's almost like a
medical process like a latch and organic
process like my brain and it may seem
too intense because there are some
characters I played which are just
fluffy characters you know they're just
hide lammers I'm a supermodel and I'm
just you know having fun that kind of
thing but even that transformation is
very organic for me as that mask is
being put I stopped being me there's
another compartment that again felt now
goes of that compartment somewhere else
and this other character comes forward
it's almost like that multiple
personality thing but hopefully only for
the camera so so yeah I literally feel
that person when I was playing the
character in Joe Joe Lolley the young
mother I had to there was this one scene
where the director said you have lost
your child react and he just turned the
camera on he didn't tell me anything
else and it took me about about two
minutes and I felt the loss possible
loss of somebody in my family who I
really really really I cannot I don't
you even now if I I don't think I can be
in this world without seeing that person
then I thought that and at that moment
the breakdown happened and it's a very
very painful process when you're doing
that kind of intense characters and you
have to organically put the intensity of
your mind into those moments you know if
I have not experienced the loss of a
young son how do you show it on film
effectively right in my and I'm not a
trained actor except for the acting
course so my acting comes from life
again coming back to that it comes from
everything I have ever experienced from
the depths of my brain I pull out that
one intense thing that I can use in that
moment and I try to bring it out in my
character and that is what that's what
happens so when you ask what happens
between walking from the makeup room to
the set I just Zone in I just become
that other person I in fact I i I've
even been told that I rude at that point
because i don't speak with anybody I'm
just gone into that character you know
so I don't know how affect how effective
is going to be for many many years
because it's very intense process to me
but but that's how I function
you